I think Napa Valley you know hate being
so anti USA right I think Napa's
massively overvalued I think I think pre
a rat in Spain is overpriced the wines
there tend to get into that sixty to
eighty dollar range I think that there's
parts of Bordeaux that are overrated i
think the left bank overshadowing the
right bank meaning poo yakin and you
know the Medoc those kind of wines
saying Steph those kind of wines tend to
get more reputation than maybe a saint
emilion and Palmer all I think it's a
mistake I think there's there's a lot of
places that get a barossa valley I mean
I like it but it's not insane so I think
there's a substantive tuska up I should
have started I mean I think Super
Tuscans in Tuscany can get very
overrated I mean so many of those wines
start at sixty seventy dollars a bottle
and I think that's insanity so you know
I think I think there's a lot I think
there's a lot especially when there's so
many underrated places like the Provence
and languid dock and and mclaren vale or
clare valley in australia i think it's
crazy okanagan in kanda you know baja
california mexico so there's it's
interesting
yellowtail gets blamed for something
that was happening also with Robert
Parker and Jay Miller's impact on
Australia let me explain what I mean by
that Robert Parker's the you know
gorilla in the room very important wine
critic and he started reading a lot of
Australian wines that were under twenty
dollars 92 93 94 points the Marquis
Philip stuff you know it's you know ball
buster from Tatum and there was whines
again big scores under 20 bucks and so
consumers started saying well I'm gonna
spend 50 when I can spend 20 and I think
yellowtail came out at the same time had
this big marketing push became this huge
brand and create a scenario where people
blamed yellowtail for everybody thinking
Australia was a ten dollar price range
category so all the premium Australian
producers really got hurt in that period
but it was really because the Parker
scores and the economy was starting to
soften and Spain and Portugal were
coming on strong with eight dollar wines
I think was a perfect storm that
yellowtail gets blamed for you know so
yellow till is executed on something
that's always worked in the US which is
good marketing and a little bit of
sweetness you know they have a little
bit more sugar levels and those Ozzie
whines then and so people like that and
it's easy to drink and kudos to them
because they were very aggressively
marketing and they really got a lot of
support from some big retailers around
the country like Sam's and total wine I
thought they played that very smart
there was a lot of smartness to what
Deutsch did there and I were a lot of
respect for the way they built a brand I
think the goodness proves that wine can
be cut you know you can still build big
brands and leveraging marketing and pop
culture I think the bad thing is is that
you know people fall in love with in
just drink that I'm not as mad about I
don't feel bad for the Australian
business people they're the ones who
relied on Parker inspected or never
built a real business in the first place
so I'm not so worried about them I'm
more worried about the consumer that
drinks a magnum of yellow tail shiraz
every night and I want them to try
different things
one thing Tony Terlato did it you know
you brought Corvo and Santa Margarita
into this country that's a quite a feat
kendall-jackson jess jackson was the
pipe in one of the first pioneers of
building a real big brand what he did
with KJ is monumental you know but
there's not a lot of innovation on the
retail side on the producer side Pete
you know everybody ripped up their
plants to plant Pinot Noir it's a lot of
chasing and and not a lot of innovating
you know it's kind of it's kind of
shocking it's probably why I was able to
do so well in that world not because I
was so good but more because of lack of
competition